shackled and wearing a blue prison
uniform elaine maxwell heard her fate
from a judge at the end of a nearly four
hour sentencing that saw several of her
alleged victims give statements
sometimes looking directly at maxwell
one was sarah ransom who broke down in
tears in court and said she twice tried
to commit suicide after being victimized
by maxwell
after the sentencing she told me she was
pleased
i'm feeling pretty amazing okay i'm
feeling great um but there is
uh you know this is a six six year
journey for me
incredible highs some really really
really deep lows for me
maxwell briefly spoke in court saying
she was sorry for the pain her victims
felt but she did not take responsibility
for the crimes
what was going through your head when
you heard elaine speak in court
[Music]
for me they were just words
but they were words that i never thought
i would ever hear is saying i'm
sorry lawyers for the victims were
satisfied with the outcome
today showed us
that
individuals can be held accountable
irrespective of power and privilege
maxwell the daughter of a british
newspaper magnet was once part of an
elite global social circle that included
some of the world's most powerful people
but at her month-long trial last
december prosecutors said she also
facilitated the trafficking of women
some as young as 14 to be sexually
abused by her longtime partner jeffrey
epstein and allegedly other rich men
epstein was arrested and charged in july
2019
but was found dead in his jail cell a
month later
before delivering her sentence the judge
said maxwell's crimes were heinous and
predatory and said she deserves a strong
sentence partially because of her lack
of remorse
elaine maxwell is 60 years old if she
serves her entire sentence that means
she wouldn't be released until she's 80.
gabrielle lozando al jazeera new york